صواريخ برينستون البريطانيه وصلت الى
اوكرانيا لجعل حياه الجنود الروس جحيمنا
تقول صحيفه التلغراف سلاح الجو الملكي
البريطاني ارسل صواريخ دريمستون وهي احدث
نسخه من الصواريخ الموجهه بالليزر ويمكنه
الوصول الى مصر بعيده القوات الاوكرانيه
قامت بتعديل الشاحنات لتكون بمثابه من
الصاد متحركه لاطلاق صواريخ برينستونه
لتدمير الدبابات الروسيه والمركبات الاخرى
من مسافه بعيده عاده يتم اطلاق الصواريخ
من الجو ولكن هذا النوع من الصواريخ الى
جانب اسلحه مماثله مضاده للدبابات ارسلها
حلفاء غربيون اخرون لاوكرانيا لعبت دورا
المحوريه في اعاقه التقدم العسكري دي
موسكو في الاشهر الاخيره اذا صواريخ خبرين
ستون يكلف كل منها حوالي وخمسه وسبعين الف
جنيه استرليني وتصيب الهدف من خلال تتبع
الليزر الذي تطلقه القوات او الطائرات او
المركبات او تحديد هدفها الخاص من خلال
قائمه مبرمجه مسبقا من خلال استخدام رادار
الموجات المليمتريه عاليه التردد يسمح هذا
النظام للسلاح بمسح ساحه المعركه تحديد
الهدف الانسب مع استبعاد المركبات المدنيه
او المعدات العسكريه الاقل الاهميه يمكن
استخدام بريمسون في المناطق السكنيه بدقه
كبيره مما يحد من احتماليه حدوث اضرار
جانبيه بين سكان المدنيين
[موسيقى]